antonio qui est venu nous voir qui lance
un militaire qui a été blessé il ya cinq
semaines il s'est pris une grenade
explosive
antonio toi qui es tu penses de la loi
anti casseurs sincèrement vous
m'entendez voyez merci à toi on vous
entend je pense que c'est encore une
fumisterie simplement loi anti casseurs
on va parler des appariteurs est ce que
cette loi va les toucher lui aussi est
ce que cette loi va toucher aussi les
fonctionnaires de police qui ont qui ont
le visage caché qui sont cachés aucun
numéro matricule pourquoi tu vois j'ai
juste une question
cette loi va toucher tout le peuple on
va toucher seulement les gens qui
revendiquent des choses comme nous faut
simplement moi je pense que cette loi en
fait elle va vous permettre de filtrer
les deux non non excusez moi même je
vous ai pas coupé laissez moi finir une
dernière chose non une dernière chose si
mature et cyril une dernière chose
comment ça se fait que vous êtes entrain
de substituer le travail des juges pour
le passé à des préfets et ça ce n'est
pas le rôle du préfet madame de faire ce
travail
c'est le rôle du juge ce n'est pas à moi
de vous le dire moi je faisais en sable
sont simples citoyens comment ça se fait
qu'aujourd'hui on en train de nous
expliquer simplement qu'on va prendre
ben écoutez ça va se passer comme ça
s'est passé il ya quelques semaines on
va arrêter des bus on va bloquer des
gens parce que en fait ils ont un gilet
sur eux bientôt la loi vous allez la
passe et on le sait très bien
mais le réel problème il est pas là
madame le réel problème est que
aujourd'hui on à christophe dettinger
qui est en prison
aujourd'hui on à monsieur andrieu qui
est dehors aujourd'hui on à monsieur
benalla qui en dehors
aujourd'hui notre ministre il va
répondre de tous les actes qu'il a fait
moi je suis pas en train de défendre mon
moulin j'ai rien à gagner moi j'ai tout
perdu et vous savez un homme qui a faim
il est prêt à tout pour nourrir sa
famille et je pense qu'aujourd'hui avec
votre aise bouffe c'est pas contre vous
madame si je suis agressif désole un
bien sûr je vais pas les abandonner
on en a marre vous nous prenez pour des
imbéciles votre loi vous allez perdre du
temps vous allez là passé mais on en a
rien à [ __ ]
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut on
veut bouffer c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
déjà je voudrais vous dire que les
moyens qu'on donne par cette loi vous
savez ce sont des policiers des
gendarmes et des magistrats qui nous ont
demandé moi j'ai mené des auditions à
l'assemblée nationale on a entendu
qu'ils avaient besoin de textes et de et
de loi en plus si on avait besoin de ces
articles là pour travailler mieux sur le
terrain c'est parce qu'on a écouté le
terrain qu'on a voté cet axe là et moi
je vous savez j'ai entendu les policiers
les gendarmes la cnil le défendeur des
droits mais aussi les services pendant
les auditions
et pour ce que vous disiez monsieur moi
je suis d'accord avec vous jean temps la
colère mais non mais écoutez moi vous
savez non non on sait ce moi j'en ai
reçus des gilet jaune aussi dans ma
circonscription dans la drôme et le
diagnostic on le partage c'est pas
normal que des gens qui galèrent alors
qu'il travaille sous la normale c'est
pas normal
il faut attendre la seule responsable et
il faut aussi vous êtes en train de nous
dire qu'effectivement vous voyez la
peine et la misère humaine mais
seulement c'est nous mettre une loi anti
casseurs c'est bien c'est nous la tva
madame et aux frci europe 1
[Applaudissements]
quoi pourquoi on signe d'apaisement le
gouvernement il avait une seule chose à
faire aller voir monsieur rodriguez
moi je suis allé le voir le mercredi
vous savez ce que j'ai fait monsieur
rodriguez
j'ai dit jérôme tu es fatigué tu as mal
s'il te plaît rang - service
fais moi un live pour calmer tous les
gens autour de moi
call me les s'il te plaît il a pris sur
lui m'a dit j'ai mal mais je vais te le
faire et c'est moi qui fais ça c'est à
vous de le faire c'est vous qui êtes
rémunéré pas moi madame merci anthony
sur la tva elle peut pas intervenir elle
peut pas fermer la tva au j'espère que
son cours et j'espère que l'on n'aura
donc on aura dirigé qu'on pourra évoquer
dans le grand débat est-ce que ça s'est
posée sur lyon